the aforementioned albert breer kind
enough to join us on short notice
but this is all happening in real time
we showed up this morning albert and all
of a sudden there was a report another
titans players tested positive
they were supposed to go back to the
facility today they got a game against
buffalo this weekend
so where do things stand i mean i with a
lot of uncertainty i think is the best
way to say it
um you know they're gonna have to wait
at least two days at least that's what
it looks like to reopen their facility
or at least attempt to reopen their
facility again
which would mean you'd be entering the
facility on friday now think about this
dan
do you think mike frable after two weeks
off is gonna have his players going full
going to practice
probably not right on friday and then
you're into saturday and that's just
a day for a walk through so you
potentially could be putting titans
players out there and this is if
everything goes okay over the next
couple of days and we're not sure about
that
um out there against the buffalo bills
um in a situation where they haven't
practiced in two weeks and so there's
player safety issues involved with this
now
um and there's you know i mean obviously
like the competitive equity
um issue too which um i think goes out
the out the window with uh with uh
with the titans but you think about like
this from the rest of the league
standpoint
i mean consider this you know the part
of the reason the chiefs
patriots game was held on monday and not
on tuesday was because the chiefs are
playing the following thursday so they
got to play three games in 10 days now
and that thursday night opponent for
them that's the buffalo bills
and if the titans bills game gets kicked
called off now the bills would be going
into that game on 11 days rest playing
against the chiefs team that had played
uh was playing for a third time in 10
days and that game
could wind up being for the number one
seed in the afc so i think that's just
like an illustration of how messy things
are
and and how you know the league's got a
real challenge on its hands right now
untangling all this but i'm trying to
understand that though
because let's say the titans game is
postponed this weekend
so now you have to make up two weeks and
can you tack it on at the end of the
season where the titans are going to be
playing
stand-alone games against pittsburgh and
buffalo
right which is not going to be fair to
pittsburgh and buffalo and some of these
other teams here so
could we i don't know if there's a
contingency plan of
winning percentage as opposed to sort of
like what we had in baseball
well i mean i i think you know start
here we knew there were going to be
competitive in equities right like and
that was something that sort of came up
in july and august when everything was
okay um
you know i think that we tried to
message that to some degree you know
that there was going to be
competitive balance problems that were
going to be created by this they
anticipated that
um you know that said i i think the
question with the titans now becomes how
much of fault were they
and there are a lot of rumors out there
about stuff that was happening in
tennessee over the last couple of weeks
and the league's investigation has been
going on there for five days now
um and if they are at fault um do you
postpone the bills game or does that
become a forfeit
um so i think that that's gonna be a
real very real question over the next
couple of days
where you know you could wind up seeing
that titans game against buffalo wind up
being
a forfeit and the titans having to take
a loss for it um
and as for where they are going forward
i mean you mention it like there's no
more
you know there's no more margin for
error with the titans and the steelers
because they've had their bye weeks well
over the next two months you're going to
start to see that come off the table for
everybody the packers and lions are on a
buy this week so after you get out of
this week just from
for natural reasons you're going to have
no more margin for error with the
packers and lines and so
i mean one answer that i think is
obvious to everybody is just to create a
week
18 at the end of the season cancel the
pro bowl and have them play the playoffs
on four consecutive weekends in january
and february
i think that that's something that could
be on the horizon um
you know like you said that creates some
competitive balance issues but i think
everybody
knew going into this year playing
through covid that those sorts of issues
were going to be there
stefan gilmore has tested positive now
they had two different planes that went
to kansas city and then came back
correct those who came in contact with
cam newton and those
who didn't right so part of the reason
why
the patriots uh trip to kansas city was
delayed was because
you know they wear those tracking
devices i'm sure you're familiar with
this dan they were
you know the wristbands and the lanyards
that kind of track who they're close to
um and so all that data when somebody
tests positive the league evaluates that
data
and you know what i was told was that
the the cam newton's data was abnormally
high
like over 20 people um had close
contacts with
with cam newton so they pushed the trip
back and the patriots make the decision
to separate
um the guys who had had close contact
with cam newton from those who had not
so all of those guys get on one plane
the rest of the team gets on another
plane they all fly to kansas city
fly back in the same fashion and then
steph gilmore's test comes up positive
tuesday going into wednesday and what do
you know
steph gilmore was one of the more than
20 close contacts of cam newton
so that of course you know calls the
question what do you do with the other
guys now who were close contacts with
cam newton how do you handle them going
forward
and then of course i think a bigger
question is if you do going forward have
guys test positive on say a friday or
saturday do you take all their close
contacts off the trip as well
um it's just it's sort of like this
pandora's box has now been opened as a
result of this
what about punishments for teams we
talked about a forfeit
but you know there's heavy fines if a
coach isn't wearing a mask but
are they talking about taking away draft
picks how serious does this get
yeah i mean this has been pretty black
and white um all week you know they said
it on a conference call it was in a
league memo
that went out to the the head coaches
and the general managers that
um there were gonna be three levels of
punishment here they didn't give
specifics on what would merit each level
of punishment but they said fines
draft picks and game forfeitures and so
you know certainly i think that you know
that that's something you could see come
into play with the titan situation based
on some of the stuff that's floating out
floating around out there on what might
have happened over the course of the
last week and a half
in nashville and then you have the
saints they are relocating to
indianapolis
for a monday night game against the
chargers that they want to play
in indianapolis and then oh by the way
hurricane delta is coming
towards new orleans
it's like a game a clue like you know
somebody with the uh
the candlestick in the butler's pantry
or whatever it is
like when do they decide on if they can
play this game in indianapolis on monday
night against the chargers
yeah i mean i you know it's it's another
one of those things where it's
just i like and look we've been through
this before where
weather has delayed games um i think the
dolphins were in one of these situations
a few years back obviously
um the texans dealt with this what was
three four years ago
um with hurricane harvey and the saints
have obviously been in these sorts of
situations
in the past so it is separate from the
coven thing
but you know in certain ways it's not
because now
you know you're going to be putting all
these guys in a plane plane and in
close proximity to one another over a
longer period of time and so
i think what's sort of interesting about
it dan is how this could sort of create
a natural bubble for the saints where
almost inadvertently the league might
get a test case here of what it might
look like if they did want to create
32 bubbles with teams going into hotels
like they'd be in
uh during like training camp or
something like that that was a uh
a quick poll by ron rivera with dwayne
haskins and now kyle allen gets the
start here is there is there
anything else to this because i looked
at haskins numbers
are better than daniel jones and he's
still the starter with the giants
right like why are they making this move
now with haskins and bringing in kyle
allen
yeah i i think there are really two
things um you know that i've heard over
the last couple of days number one
um you know i i don't think that they
feel like haskins is running the offense
at the level they want it run
and um you know so really from that
standpoint it's about the other 10 guys
in the huddle um and that's the way that
coaches look at these things
is he holding back terry mclaurin is he
holding back antonio gibson is he
holding back the other people that he's
playing with and
i think the coaches there felt like um
the best thing for the other 10 guys in
the huddle right now
would be to have a guy out there who's
seeing the field a little bit better
who's going into his progressions a
little bit deeper and then
the second piece of it is you know
related to that which is just that they
don't feel like haskins has come along
quick enough
and so i think it's pretty telling that
they knocked him down to third on the
depth chart which means he probably
won't
dress for the game against the rams like
they really feel like they gotta sit him
down for a little bit and just kind of
reset him
um i think that tells you all you need
to know about where they feel he is in
his development
there's all this dabo sweeney talk
because there's coaching vacancies
and you know would he go to the texans
and i was told no he wouldn't go to the
texans but then
it was brought up to me yesterday what
if the falcons job is open
and they have the number one pick in the
direction like do you see a scenario
where dabo sweeney would actually leave
clemson to coach in the nfl
so you know i like i know that there's
interest in him and i know he's been on
lists
and that's you know how all these things
start um
you know whether or not he would
actually do it i don't know um
i don't know nearly well enough to to be
able to say one way or the other but i
do think there's going to be opportunity
out there for them
and what's so interesting about this and
college coaches know this i mean if dabo
asked nick saban
what would nick saban say about his
experience with the dolphins be
get yourself a quarterback because
that's what i didn't do in miami
um and so you know if dabo has it in his
head at some point i want to take my
shot in the nfl
who his quarterbacks going to be is a
big part of that and
you know who which quarterbacks does he
have the best background on he has the
best background under sean watson he has
the best background on trevor lawrence
and so
if say a jacksonville or in atlanta
wound up with the number one overall
pick and dabo had it in the back of his
head
i got to take my shot at some point at
doing this i want to try the nfl
you know he would want to take it with a
guy he trusts at the most important
position on the field and
so i think going to a team you know with
the number one overall pick would
you know certainly be enticing for him
and i do think the one thing to keep an
eye on with the houston situation there
uh dan a lot of people don't know this a
lot of people appointed jack easter b's
relationships in new england
i'm told that jack easter b is very very
close with clemson coach dabo swinney
and so you know to me like the idea
there that like
maybe jack easterby could sort of plant
the seed and start
and he's the gm is he the president he's
like basically
he's the evp of football operations
which is amazing because he's gone from
team chaplain in kansas city
the character coach in new england wait
wait now he's basically running the show
wait he was a chaplain he was a chaplain
yep a chaplain with the chiefs um and he
wound up
in fact the reason now think about this
like he he was the chaplain of the
chiefs when the javon belcher tragedy
happened yeah and scott pioli was the gm
he wound up in new england because scott
piolli said
said to bill belichick there's the best
guy to handle this aaron hernandez
situation for you is right here it's
jack easterby
he rose to the ranks in new england and
then he winds up in houston with bill
o'brien
and now with o'brien fired he's the
top-ranking football official in houston
and again i'm told that he has a very
close relationship with dabo and so
i mean the idea that maybe jack easterby
could sell dabo on the idea i'm going to
let you run the football operation here
and you get to come work with desean
like i like again like i'm not i'm not
i'm not refuting what you're trying to
say
about him not going there but i would
think that one of jack's first phone
calls would probably be to dabble either
to try to get him to go there
or or to get advice on what he should do
great stuff albert we appreciate your
time thanks for joining us
awesome thanks dan that's albert brier
senior nfl reporter
and uh he works for mmqb